Pope Francis presided over Good Friday
services at Saint Peter's Basilica in
Rome the Day commemorates the
crucifixion of Jesus Christ and is the
most solemn day on the catholic calendar
in paris a spokesman for the fire
department says no trade on is now
stable after the massive fire that all
but gutted the cathedral Roxana Saberi
is in Paris and joins us now with more
Roxana good morning good morning the
Paris prosecutor's office is urging
people who are donating money to rebuild
no trade on to beware of scams the
spokesman for the Cathedral told us the
donations keep pouring in as
investigators continue to search for
what sparked the fire in the days after
flames devoured the roof of Notre Dame
Cathedral leaving a hole where its spire
once stood firefighters raced to cool
down the walls so they would also
crumble now they say that danger has
passed so investigators can access more
of the site and then the firearm just
rang notre dom spokesman andre Fino told
us it could take weeks to learn what
caused the fire but he doesn't think it
was linked to renovations taking place
when the blaze broke out there is too
many predictions on this
[Music]
these renovations with these scenes
resonating beyond France's borders
people around the world have pledged
more than 1 billion dollars to rebuild
no trade off we don't know if it's
enough on us really can say it's a crazy
to have a billion euros but we don't
know we don't know maybe below costs 2
or 3 billion rebuilding is likely to
take years which means ceremonies like
this good friday procession yesterday
that usually take place inside the
cathedral will have to be held in its
shadows the Archbishop of Paris told
worshippers commemorating the
crucifixion of Jesus Christ France is
crying and the world is crying with us
the Easter Mass that was supposed to be
held at Notre Dame has also been moved
it's now set to take place tomorrow at a
church just a short walk from here
Anthony
Roxana thanks a billion euros that's an
extraordinary amount of money to come in
so quick 180 just to renovate it when
they were in the midst of that so a lot